today i'll show you how to code a
third-person camera
from scratch in 3js by the end of this
tutorial
you'll understand how third-person
cameras work you'll understand how to
design the architecture for a game
and you'll understand how to code this
all up in short you'll be able to build
this
and we'll walk through every step of the
way explaining everything as we go
so let's start by quickly going over
what we mean by a third person camera
like what is that there are a few
commonly used cameras used by games and
they tend to fall into two categories
you've got first person cameras which is
kind of like a point of view camera
where you see through the eyes of the
protagonist
there's like a jillion examples of this
doom and other shooters always come to
mind
then there's third person cameras and
you see it a lot in games too where the
camera is kind of creeping along behind
the player
keeping both them and the environment in
view at the same time
it's like a bird's eye view or you could
imagine if a drone was following you and
recording everything you do
which while also super creepy would be
exactly what a third person camera is
in a game and i can probably think of a
million games that use this vantage
point like here we've got horizon zero
dawn
and you can see that the camera kind of
floats behind the character
often slightly offset to the character's
right as if it's looking over their
shoulder
other games might use a more centered
one mario comes to mind
see how the camera follows with
everything much more centered
but the gist of it is they follow the
player looking roughly in the same
direction
so there's a few parts that make up the
behavior of the camera then
say we have a player standing here and
i'll just draw some crappy little guy
standing on the ground
and now we'll represent the camera with
this eye thing up here
your first intuition might be to really
just take the camera
point it at the player offset it by a
specific
x y coordinate so now when the player
moves the camera trails along looking at
them
but look back to some of the videos of
other games the camera isn't looking
directly at them
it's actually looking in the same
direction as they are it's looking
ahead of them so back here in our sketch
the camera isn't looking
directly at the player what it should be
doing is looking ahead
wherever the player is looking like this
we've picked a spot ahead of the player
and the camera is kind of looking in
that direction
instead the other thing that the camera
needs to do is follow the player
look at this footage of that new wukong
game and watch how the camera swings
around as the player moves
notice that the camera isn't necessarily
fixed completely to the player like it's
a gopro on a helmet
but many games add a little bit of
dampening in there like the camera is
fixed to a spring that is attached to
the player
that way the camera moves much more
smoothly more naturally
okay so let's start thinking about code
the first thing we want to do is take a
step back
and try to think about the design so
that whatever we end up with is future
proof
and doesn't come back to bite us down
the road how i would do this
is to decouple input character movement
and camera logic into separate
isolated components and although for
this crappy little demo it won't matter
in the slightest
down the road you can do things like
make an ai character by simply reusing
the character movement behavior but make
it puppeted by an ai
instead which is neat because you're
getting a bunch of reuse here
so all great code starts with copy
pasting from somewhere so like always
we're just going to reuse some existing
code to get started
i'll start by creating this 3js tutorial
third person camera directory and then
i'm just gonna copy the character
controller code in there to get going
if you haven't seen that video
definitely go check it out
let's start by creating a new class
third person camera
and this will contain all of the logic
for keeping the camera fixed to the
player
following them around and doing it
smoothly
we'll assume that the actual camera
we're manipulating gets passed in by
the params so we can just go like this
dot underscore camera equals
params.camera down in the main setup
code we'll actually instantiate the real
3js camera
so we'll just set up a perspective
camera here we just need to set up all
the parameters
we're not going to do anything special
here 5 is 60
aspect ratio is just width over height
near and far
one in a thousand respectively and we
instantiated a perspective camera with
those parameters
right underneath this is where we'll
instantiate the new third-person camera
and the first parameter it needs is the
three gas camera so we'll call
new third person camera and in the
params we'll set the 3js camera
we'll also need to update this new
camera each frame so down in the step
function we'll add this line this dot
underscore third person
dot thirdpersoncamera.update with the
time elapsed as the parameter
what this will do is give us an entry
point each frame to do any bookkeeping
and update necessary for the camera so
if the player moves for example
this update function will see the
character move and smoothly move to
follow
let's fill in the third person camera
class now and what you may be surprised
to see is that this will be a really
short class
first thing is the constructor will have
two member properties this dot current
position and this dot current
look at and these will be responsible
for tracking the current position of the
camera and the current position the
camera is looking
the next thing we want to do is go down
here and add an update function
if you recall in the main step function
we specifically called the camera's
update function
and that was to give the camera some
time to do any internal logic needed
now we have to actually implement this
so the first thing we want to do is add
those two values that we need to compute
i'll just add a quick comment here
saying that we'll have to come back and
actually fill these in
but we've declared ideal offset and
ideal look at
we're going to go ahead and use them
right away and so down here i'll take
the 3js camera that was passed in as a
parameter
and i'll set the position directly to
ideal offset
and you can use position.copy to do that
now we need to orient the camera to look
at the ideal look at position
and that's a simple call the camera.look
at and pass ideal look at as the
parameter
now let's go back and actually fill in
values for ideal offset
and ideal look at we'll add a function
calculate ideal offset and that will be
used to compute the ideal position
of the camera given the current position
of the character
and i'll define the function itself and
it'll just involve a little bit of
vector math
we'll start with an offset so i'll just
do this by hand for now and we'll hard
code a value
i'll just make the camera a bit behind
the character and a little bit over
their shoulder
the next thing you do is copy the
character's orientation
since the offset is in local space so
that's what this line
apply quaternion with the target's
rotation as a parameter does
finally we just add the character's
position and that should give us the
final value so we just return it
we also need to do nearly the exact same
thing for ideal look at so let's just
call that
so ideal look at equals this dot
calculate ideal look at
and then we'll go up here and we need to
define a function called calculate ideal
look at
now the body of the function will be
nearly identical to calculate ideal
offset
in that we start with some sort of
offset in this case i'm going to hard
code an offset ahead of the character in
local space
then we call apply quaternion with the
character's rotation which is exactly
what we did previously
and that will just orient the target
position in the right direction
finally we add the character's position
and return the value
you may notice that these two functions
are nearly identical and
in fact as a nice refactoring step i'll
probably go back and collapse these into
a single function
anyway in the update function we've just
used these two values directly in the
camera and look at
functions so let's load this up and see
how it feels
here's the character and we can walk
around and notice how the camera is
trailing and it's working pretty well
considering how little work this was
but notice as i turn around and swing
around move the camera always
follows super exactly there's no natural
motion to it
we need to make some small modifications
in the code to get the natural springy
feel
back in the update function there's a
few approaches we can take
i'll show you a super simple way that
isn't quite right
and then we'll explore some better ones
after that so the absolute simplest
thing you can do
is something you often see is something
like this we'll take the current
position and call lerp on the ideal
position
so this dot currentposition.lerp into
the ideal position
and what this means is that every frame
given two positions will interpolate a
percentage of the way between them
so let's say we've got this start and
end point and after one frame we
interpolate a percentage of the way
there
so we're about here now then the next
frame we do the same thing
given the new starting point and the end
we interpolate the same percentage of
the way
and so on what ends up happening is the
point smoothly slows down as it reaches
the goal
so let's see this in action when we load
this up notice how the camera has a
little bit of a slow start stop
kind of like it's accelerating
decelerating
and if we were to spin around we get a
cool effect where the camera has this
nice natural feel to it
you can of course play with the
coefficient increasing it means the
camera moves much more exactly with less
of a spring but still some
i'll drop back down into the code for a
second and let's change the value from
0.05 to 0.15
now when we load that up the camera is
much crisper while still retaining just
a bit of spring
so honestly you could stop here this
works pretty well and
a lot of people do but there's a problem
and it's that your camera movement
isn't frame rate independent we're
lurping by a constant amount every frame
your first thought might be to factor in
the frame time to the lerp coefficient
and that does work although it's not
quite right let's try it out
we can change the coefficient by
multiplying by the frame time
so in the code all we need to do is i'll
comment out the old one and add a new
coefficient
constant t equals 4.0 times time elapsed
i just chose this because at 30fps this
is roughly equal to 0.12 give or take
so somewhat similar to what we were
working with before
loading that up you're not going to see
that much different it looks roughly the
same but in theory if the frame rate
dips or if you run this on another
machine with a massively higher frame
rate
the camera should act mostly the same
mostly but not quite
and that's because it's not fully frame
rate independent
to get this to be fully frame rate
independent we're going to need to
modify the coefficient again
to something that's not at all intuitive
but works
here we'll comment out the old one and
then we'll declare this new one
this will be t equals 1.0 minus math.pal
0.001 and to the power time elapsed
this isn't going to be massively
different from the previous version just
slightly more correct
and to prove it's more correct we'll
actually run some numbers to prove the
differences
here's a block of testing code that
we're going to use and this will
simulate the effects of running at two
different frame rates
one at 100 fps and one at 50 fps
and all the code is doing is running in
a loop doing lerps over and over again
starting at a start value and moving
towards the end value
and so when we use the constant value in
this case we use the constant of 0.01 to
illustrate the difference
when we write out the final values what
we end up with is something like
63 versus 39 see how at 100 fps versus
50 fps
we ended up with a big difference and
that's only over the course of a single
second
the slightly corrected version that
factors in the frame rate does better
but still isn't right
so in this case what i got was 63.39
versus 63.58 notice how close this got
but they're not quite the same there are
actually some small differences over
time that would accumulate if you were
running this over like 5-10 seconds
so we'll use the last equation i'm going
to use 1.0 minus math.pal
0.3 to the time elapsed and these are
damn near identical down to some small
floating point differences that are
under like the 17th digit
as good as we're going to get today and
here we can compare visually
so here's the first version i'll just
artificially screw with the frame rate
so on the left we have full frame rate
on the right i've introduced a
bottleneck on the main thread just to
force the frame rate down
notice how on the right how as i spin
you can see the camera lags pretty
noticeably
normally i can't see much of the
character's face but at least with these
settings in the artificially slow
version
he's able to spin around a lot more
while the camera struggles to catch up
let's look at the final version now so
on the left is full frame rate on the
right we've got
our artificially slowed down version
there's not a world of difference here
anymore it
mostly looks the same give or take and
that's where we're going to stop this
tutorial because we've covered enough to
give you the basic mechanics of a third
person camera
obviously there's a lot more complexity
to explore but this should get you going
at least
like and subscribe check out the code on
github and if you've got things that you
want to see covered in the future
let me know until next time cheers